that's very strange doesn't it we can
still play your move king CA okay so
here the difference is that I I cost you
a lot of time to go after this pawn on
it I've caught I've cost you a tempo to
go after my rook and I'm looking at the
pawn on b5 and in this case rookie five
unlike when our Knight was on d4 rookie
five is not very effective you forced me
to play instead of king well yeah no
after king ca oh pardon me so I was
looking at night well first of all what
about work Ricky five immediately I have
83 and mm-hmm well after rookie 593
there is a pen at the moment so yeah be
a little bit careful that night I got f4
on my agenda and I've got Knight takes
b5 it also not compromised thank you of
this pin on the night so night b1 is a
crafty retreating move not not the move
yet unique what you want to do like what
you are what how you play like a girl
activate your pieces try to get in there
94 96 but exactly well actually end up
being the one but it performs the most
vital function to get name divided right
exactly it's a it has a dual role
attacking the pawn on b5 defending the
pawn on d5 and that's key Maurice has
some insights that you'd like to share
any believe indeed on a couple of boards
I'd like to show some interesting
developments in this position Lenderman
who's our leader played the move B for
his pawn was already controlling those
pawns and he decided I don't need that I
want to rip apart that King and create
counter play rip apart that pawn shield
that is around the king so after b4 King
b3 b takes c3 b takes c3 and now he's
beginning the perpetual harassed
spin off the white King you played Queen
to eight and we know these are the kinds
of positions it's really difficult to
promote this pawn because the Queen is
going to be bothering this King with
checks from multiple angles there's no
pawn shield this King will ever find and
this Bishop controlling this pawn on
this square as well so it looks as
though Linderman feels this is just a
draw you're not going to beat me in this
position
I've got nothing over here but your king
is just too exposed and he's probably
right in that analysis another game we
want to take a look at is the game
between Ramirez and Molnar and Ramirez
in this position we saw this game he's
already up to solid pawns and after
Queen to g4 he just said I'm gonna push
Queen to f4 and now he played this
sequence Queen check Mullen went down
the board with this move anything was
losing but this allows a trade of Queens
if Ramirez once said he's gonna have to
pass pawns over here and another one
over here the move King to h3 was played
in this position so he could trade
Queens well in fact just playing the
move a4 if he chooses to another
development that I want to get at is the
game with I swore on this position s
Warren is still working on this position
trying to get that win but it's very
hard to get out of the shelter right
here and the pieces of frozen on this
side you can't capture this pawn because
this pawn would be captured so it looks
like though no progress there but back
to another position guys this position
yes it looks like sitarski is not
figuring out that fortress you discuss
and instead she's brought her bishop
over on this square and has weakened her
pawn structure just a little bit it
looks like black might be making some
progress in this position so lots going
on on different boards people still
trying to win some games this particular
one will be huge for the championship in
the woman's side because lost by
sitarski would just devastate her
chances of winning the whole thing of
course she still has to face crush
eventually but this would not be a good
way to proceed with the white pieces
losing to one of the lower rated players
in the field back to you guys yeah this
h3
doesn't make a good impression does it a
3d weakening right making it even harder
to make a poor dress well one of the
things that black needs to do that I
always thought they move h5 was very
useful but I think on a might in that
position want to play h4 and try to
freeze that H pawn from making any
further progress let me bring that game
up on our board because that is actually
crucial before the tournament I really
felt I'm no genius but I really felt
that the the women's championship was
going to come down to a two-person race
between arena and Ana and I always
thought that their matchup was going to
decide the championship itself when they
do play do we know penultimate round but
who has the white pieces okay you'll
double check that and we'll just go back
and investigate these last two moves by
the players Queen d3 as expected
yes arena as white okay that's that's
huge
King g7 fine h3 and not a move that I
think is very good and now the move
h5 this makes it really really tough on
white to decide what is the ideal setup
on the let me show you why I think that
having this pawn on h3 instead of h2 is
wrong because after this type of a pawn
sacrifice now this pawn gets to f4 and
this is absolutely easily winning
suddenly because your next move is going
to be Queen III check and why can't keep
up the blockade after a move like Bishop
f3 Queen III check King g2 Queen e1 and
we see
a huge difference now with the pawn on
f4 before the pond was always staying on
g3 right you never had access to the g3
square but guess what the blockade can't
be kept the whole gang was good enough
as well so I that that's why I that that
that move h3 sent a shiver up my spine
does not look when you're trying to
create a fortress the idea is that you
don't create more weakness is that the
the pawns should you stay back
so they least the king came to read mom
you should write books there you go try
encourage it Jim Maurice what is your
take on this yes yes it looks as though
there's some serious business going on
in the Ray Robson game not just on the
board but in particular on the clock
we're not surprised right ray his
biggest weakness everyone talks about is
his love of time pressure well I don't
know if he would say he loves time
pressure but he always seems to get into
time pressure and in this game it's no
different he has only two minutes and 53
seconds left on his clock of course with
increments that's kind of a fake number
because he gets 30 seconds every time he
moves but nevertheless he's under a lot
of pressure here
and his opponent instead has 27 minutes
Plus trying to figure out the best moves
not a great place for him to be
especially with this position where he
is worse he's played the move b3 his
rook is very precariously placed on that
side of the board after takes takes and
came to b8 he has to drop his rook back
and by the way I should point out this
fine move that was played by narrow disc
II this f5 move freezing everything on
this side and now he can just play King
to b7 and this rook looks a little bit
ridiculous in fact the move
a4 can be met by b4 and again look at
this rook it's caged defended by this
night but this rook is free to roam
going down into the position picking off
a pole
all kinds of dangers here for the white
pieces add to the fact that he's in time
pressure as well this does not bode well
for Ray Robson so in serious trouble
here if narrow disc he can just find a
few good moves
he might be well on his way to his first
win here in the championships guys very
good very good and in the game between
boy they always get her name that's
Lauren s one she we reached a position
where it's a kind of a zoo coastline
black can't bring her King out and
prepare to promote her pond because
after checks there's just a whole series
of checks so s Warren was forced to move
her rook and played the move rook g3 and
white got the exact ending that Maurice
was talking about and after the trade
this H pond is going to force black to
sacrifice her rook one day one day and
this variation that I'm showing and the
game will be agreed a draw this game
will this be yes it will be s Warren's
first draw all of her results to this
moment and you guys are killers
really so it does appear that s Warren's
technique unfortunately
thirteen-year-old inexperienced didn't
she she did have a winning position that
was for sure and she just let it slip
away
and it goes to show you that you want to
try to find those rectangles when you're
in the losing side also was able to save
herself because steering them into
steering exactly yeah all right very
good a lot of games going on today they
are fighting today we've also got
we've looked at a burg Lenormand that's
still going on we looked at that
recently though it looks like yours is
gonna win narrow duties on top Gotti of
also in a rook ending that looks very
balanced still a little bit of an edge
for a Cobian as explained by Maurice
still balanced one two three three
versus three rook ending the difference
here in this rook ending and why I like
a Cobian chances these doubled eight
pawns are kind of scraggly no passed
pawn on the a file that be seven pounds
but conversely black has an opportunity
to black has a passed pawn pass C pawn
he has an opportunity try to advance
this pawn and in conjunction with his
King tried to win White's r up for the
pawn so that's why I like a Kobe ins
chances but because the material is so
reduced I wouldn't I
I see more drawing chances than winning
chances for Akopian so this game
probably heading fer draw that advantage
for bar one game we haven't looked at
yet no one is championship between two
players who you know are always a threat
to the leaders right then you can upper
ha me on yes then you've the only player
to Nick Irene across mm-hmm for a draw
so far or eliminating the possibility of
a Fisher Price by the way the last
player to I know in the US Women's
Championship was Anna Guk oh yeah that's
it was why I was thinking Donald that
was what is the wife of Boris Coco -
very very famous dissidents at the time
coming from the Soviet Union and I'm
borescope Coco came to America and
interestingly having won the Soviet
championship winning B when the US
Championship as well I think that's
quite remarkable
and this game with zhenya also fairly
balanced but I kind of like blacks
position somehow here even though you
have this white part knee has this past
beep on which could be very threatening
the reality is once the rook gets behind
that beep on it really isn't going
anywhere and on the other side of the
board
just be careful that you don't allow a
mating net to be set up with h4 Knight
g3 rook coming to h1 and we have a
result today for the standees Arenberg
and Lenderman we thought this game was
steering towards a draw and they have to
Cannes the game is a draw a hard-fought
one I think that Alex will be very
pleased with the result he mixed it up
in the opening playing something he
never played before well prepared
Sergei held in the edge in my opinion
but nothing very very significant and
good well in the words have gotta Kamsky
professional draw and that doesn't hurt
Lenderman at all he skates by with the
black and maintains a wonderful +3
record so for from 5 Arenberg had some
chances to push but i still admired his
choice to play the sicilian yes I'm sure
we will success it's a great feeling and
it was a very successful debut for the
Sicilian for I think it was a success
because the suffering was rather minimal
in my view and especially after g4 h 4 I
thought that that was not the most that
didn't that that didn't allow white to
get in the best punch right Wonderman
has to say about his chance in this game
whether he was pleased with his opening
or not be very curious to know what he
felt were those critical moments where
the outcome was decided exactly I'm set
up with Grand Master Maurice Ashley
right now I would like to give you guys
an opportunity reminder that you can
tweet us questions and if we can fit
them in and ask the guests we'll do it
so right hashtag us chest chin ups or
comments I'd say it was just enough
network send your questions in and
they're ready so we've got our
tournament leader Alexandre under ban
with Maurice Ashley thanks Jen we are
with grandmaster alex alexander
Lindemann first of all congratulations
on your draw or maybe you don't feel
that way about it are you satisfied with
the result you had today sure was a good
battle you know I think I did my best so
I was happy your opening choice seemed
unusual for you is this special
preparation you had I'm asking that
tongue-in-cheek of course because
obviously your preparation has been
really good in this tournament why did
you choose this variation well
concretely for Sergey I think these
short positions I think that they're not
of they're not in circus flavor and you
know it was a concrete analysis it's a
very dangerous position but me and
George and my coach decided that on for
this one game it's probably a good
option interesting how you're varying
your openings in the tournament it seems
like you're really well prepared for
this event
Chomsky mentioned that he thinks players
were preparing maybe for even a month
before the event leading up to it he's
never seen such really sterling
preparation would you agree with him uh
for me for you and the other players in
the top well sure I mean you know I I
try to like I said get better every day
so I always do some general preparation
but for this term that try to play
different stuff because I also try to
avoid other people's preparation did you
come into this championship with
expectations you so far you're really
doing very well leading the tournament
by yourself right now calm ski drew
today looks like your gravel will also
all kind draw his game very likely in
fact his opponent is
saying did you come in with any
expectations in the tournament or did
you expect to be doing this well well I
try not like it first of all to answer
your first question I didn't really have
any expectations I was just trying to do
the best I can and one move at a time
one game at a time and give it my
maximum effort every game as for
expecting to do well I mean I'm not
surprised that I'm doing well I feel
like I'm it's it's always a possibility
but I didn't exactly explicitly think
you know what result I'll be having so
because that's just extra distraction
and I still try not to think about
results and against Sam Shanklin who you
have tomorrow what's your record against
him and how do you feel going into the
game I feel pretty confident my record
is not that great against him but well
actually this is the first white I'm
getting in in it's the ninth game we're
playing long game and it's the first
time I'm playing white Wow
all the other games had black you know
had some missed opportunities but I like
I said I also had a very bad record
against Sergei Lemberg so like I said
it's it's an new tournament no game I
try to put all the other games behind me
and I was a different person back then
like I said I try to get better every
time so I try not to let it get let it
affect me indeed well we wish you the
best in your future games playing really
well right now
thanks Grandmaster Alex Lindemann our
tournament leader really blazing new
territory for him and sitting pretty
right now in the US Championships back
to you Jenna yes out of hi we didn't
find the critical positions but it
seemed to air from the way
Alex was describing the battle he really
just didn't feel like he had ever had
any problems in this game and it was
just a good well fought hard-fought draw
as well but I wanted to bring up a
Ramirez owner because he's having a cute
little night checkmate okay oh why it's
not really a checkmate but it'd be clear
I just uh always pretty to see these
checkmates with weak pieces which we see
what we saw a lot today and Irina's game
so magic in trouble
Queen f2 sets up the threat of the
retreating knight move so we actually
made the maneuver Queen c5 back half to
one is the idea now that the pawn on h2
is defended by the Queen nygean would
win blacks Queen by the way do I do you
see a defense to this move this move
looks really really strong you'd have to
move the Queen out of the way
but wherever you move the Queen really
looks kind of ugly there's simply a
different checkmate to be had here
oh the checkmate I had in mind was to
play h3 she was pretty good yeah it only
wins a piece I was trying for I was
trying to win a king but that that's
winning and it looks to me like this
nice retreating move but Queen f2 seems
to wrap up the game nice moves that's
not what you expect for the final
combination but right there you go
that's a good one and Mac is about the
tumble I believe to a second defeat in a
row after playing very solid through the
first three rounds that blunder against
Gary EV I guess simply put he hasn't
recovered from it and a nice win for our
runner-up and we do have a 38 Berg with
us to talk about his draw against the
tournament leader indeed grandmaster
circuit Ehrenburg who's showing me lines
and saying he thinks he was winning it
feels like it was a lost opportunity for
himself welcome to the show Sergey you
feel like you had a real chance here
that you let slip through your fingers
I felt like could be thinking is close
to be winning I might be wrong I thought
that the either be three or can be three
in this position would lead to a very
tough
in public maybe computers see some
escape computer always see something
yeah I mean the thing is that if I
manage to exchange bishops it's
completely been in position for Wyatt
because I my king will approach d5 pawn
and I will just take it because black
doesn't have any counter play he's King
this completely passive I felt like I
completely outplayed my opponent but he
defended well and I don't yeah I didn't
use my chances well as always in this
time he's been playing really well
though so far even when he's worse he's
somehow coming up with moves what do you
think that is it's just pure form or or
just Lux no I mean it's definitely not
just luck and if he's lucky he he makes
like he makes maximum out of his chances
by fighting hard I mean yeah you
definitely need some help from upon your
opponent's when you are in trouble like
he was against Garre for in this game
but yeah he's having a great tournament
and he's he's deserved leader now you're
at minus one right now it's 2-2 even
actually yeah so how do you how do you
dig out of this hole I mean you're
playing good moves but somehow I mean
yes agree I feel like I also I thought
really nice position with black pieces
against Garvin gata Kamsky I'm just
collapse completely collapse at some
point I don't know how to explain it
sometimes you know it's not yet
tournament I mean I'll try to do my best
and I'll keep playing the way I do I'll
keep playing fighting chess and I'll try
to bring ok subsequent games well we
hope you win a few games in the next few
rounds thanks for joining us some of it
you the best in the rest of the games
thank you
Grandmaster Sergei Ehrenberg still
kicking himself over yesterday's game in
today's games gotta clear his mind so he
can finish off for this tournament
strong guys thank you thank you wait
yeah Wow while we were on camera there
Maurice Jen and I are like looking into
each other back and forth because of the
game but with Mac that's right we have a
funny finish and Ramirez Mackenzie boner
if you want to pull that up yeah so it's
on my screen okay and
we were discussing how noisy once seemed
impossible to me and we were also
discussing earlier depart house how
these two young men are friends and
actually Mulder in this position
apparently according to the TGT played
bishop to g3 allowing a checkmate in one
move the beautiful night Jiwon would you
this is not not the only beautiful
checkmate we saw today and the
championship right beautiful night mate
but it's right but it's so rare that
grandmasters actually allow a checkmate
to be executed at the board usually
they'll resign before the checkmate
itself is executed makes you wonder if
maybe it was because it was such a cool
attack right actually the defending
champion she she once had this really
nice gaming and stefanov oh where she
had this beautiful right check me that
was a smother made and I I was always a
little sad that when you look at the end
of that game like her opponent resigns a
couple moves before instead of allowing
it to be the audience there is something
courteous when your opponent has a
really sweet checkmate
let them play I'm gonna pour it mm-hmm
my students also appreciate it okay and
we got a Maurice for that more on that I
think everyone appreciates it I was
thinking about this wondering for myself
as I sort of go into the role of a
promoter and organizer of chess how
would you incentivize a player to play
to checkmate because the general
audience that we're trying to appeal to
really wants to see the finish of the
game they want to see the conclusion but
as chess player is if you're down like a
rook or a queen you're just not going to
play more moves simply out of respect
actually to your opponent I don't really
know what the solution is to that one
I'd love it if some folks out there came
up with a way to make that possible
because it's just it's just one of those
challenges I thought of a lot of
different innovations but that one
I'm just clueless it's like how do you
get players to play to mate or to play
out when they're just dead busted or
maybe just the audience has to just
simply assume and understand that it was
over and then leave it to us the
commentators to explain the rest seems
anticlimactic somehow when we always
have to explain it that I think is one -
in our sport that really somehow I don't
know how to resolve but it would be
great if we could I think you can solve
it
especially in rapid events in a
classical time control it might be a
little trickier but when we had the
extreme Chess Championships which was a
30 minute championship we just told the
players play to check me in every game
and they just did it it was a roll it
was a roll in the competitions well they
were but they weren't paid extra for the
checkmate but they kind of got used to
it it's like okay like they start moving
quickly towards the end when they're
dead lost and the guy check ridiculous
in the beginning but then maybe if it
becomes more organizers start doing it
like the Sofia rose it'll be like oh
this is a checkmate tournament and
people will get used to it I the only
thing is in a classical time control it
could be annoying because my vision is
if you're dead lost it's only gonna
really add three minutes to the game
because somebody would just like blitz
out Queen versus King checkmate whatever
but the concern is in a classical time
control would it add twenty minutes to
the game thirty minutes that could be
annoying yes indeed and that would drag
it on you basically want to tell them
listen when you're losing just lose
quick there's another problem with that
I think it just really is a serious
challenge but as I said a lot of the
rules in chess are established only
because they've been there for so long
it doesn't mean that they necessarily
belong there they're that they're
superior to other ways we've been
talking about different ways to handle
draws thirty move rules and all that
even clocks you know those rules have to
change after the advent of the digital
era so I think any rule can be
implemented as long as the players are
okay with it so that we can start to try
to popularize our sport we can't live in
the past I think that's definitely a bad
place for us to be because those those
ways are just outdated particularly in
this much much more speedy era so I
agree we need some some organ
putting their feet down like boom listen
you gotta get made it son that's gonna
be a hard window I gotta tell you you
must play to checkmate mmm I think
that's particularly good for things like
I know Maurice is shooting a little
segments for Fox Sports Midwest right
for something small like that so you can
tell people this was where it ended this
was the check man that's kind of sweet
when you're editing you to be able to
have that moment of finality right I am
really gonna have to give that one more
thought because I just don't see the top
grandmasters as being amenable maybe you
could start small in a rapid competition
I say start with beginners they start
with beginner tournaments and see if
they like they already played a
technique a lot of them do but then then
then go up and see if elite grandmasters
would alright then I think about a rapid
competition is that it you know a lot of
times when somebody's losing they only
haven't made it left on the clock anyway
so it's like either play really quickly
true and get checkmated or lose on time
either one is somewhat dramatic right
but as far as the resignation cars go I
mean wouldn't a player just lose on time
just like it's play slower and he'll be
unsportsmanlike and boring okay is if
there were a bonus for for some kind of
tiebreak bonus for how long you lasted
in your games uh-huh right so if at the
end you will get some kind of bonus as
being the person who played the longest
games then let's say those money
involved then players might say okay
well then I'm gonna play the checkmate
and I'm gonna make it really hard for
you to check being me in fact because I
want that money bonus at the end so if
you had let's say a five grand bonus
for the longest games people are not
gonna resign just because they lose a
piece or pawn or you know something like
let's keep playing
cuz I'm gonna drag this out drag this
out make it hard because at the end I'm
gonna collect five grand in my pocket I
think something like that the players
might might buy into and and especially
if you could even raise the money a
little bit higher you know what if it's
ten grand
all right then of course they might play
on there too much money well but but
even so I mean game's not really because
it's both players well position you
could deliberately take a little bit
longer to checkmate that that's true
that is true yeah that's what that's why
they're just holds in different ideas
and I haven't come up with something
that satisfied me yet but I'm working on
it trust me
I want to see mate I think start with
rapping and it's it's painless and see
how it goes and people start to get used
to it and we do have an official draw
it's Warren and Mel Akina
was the first draw between those two
players I can't wait to hear what the
story is with Ramirez molnár and whether
that was a gentlemanly checkmate offer
that was a potato at the hole let's get
ourselves checkmated discussion I can't
see how to stop my two on maybe we
should be 3oe I'm not so happy with how
Victoria has handled her Queen versus
rook and Bishop position against Anna it
seems to me like Victoria's rather lost
the threat of it I had been suggesting
that from this position a long long long
long time ago that all that Victoria
really needed to do was to transfer her
Queen to the e1 square and after h5h we
everything was going well and then why
do I see suddenly this move Queen d4
popping up on them excuse why don't I
see the move h5h for just
making it possible for Victoria to bring
her King into the position so first
start I don't get this and then after a
series of checks that have gone back and
forth we do have this position and now I
think Ana has excellent drawing chances
let's just play a move or two so I can
at least explain what I think is
happening what I think is happening is
that Ana is going to be allowed given
the opportunity I mean to trade her g4
pawn for the d2 pawn and then it's going
to be rook and Bishop versus Queen and
pawn but that's really excellent chances
of a draw so Victoria letting her
advantage slip greatly in this game
indeed and Maurice Ashley for some
thoughts on the Robson guard it's a game
where is that rook going to escape no
it's not it's clear that right now
Robson is in trouble
and in time trouble as well as he
usually is so in a very difficult
position he played the move rook to a5
and King to b7 and that King is
eyeballing that rook trying to hold it
down the move a4 was played and the
youngster found before keeping the rook
entombed in the position the move Knight
to d2 happened rook to e1 and now Knight
to c4 is on the board looking to somehow
take on d6 but this is a very good
position after the move rook to c1 which
has not been played as yet Robson is in
big trouble
because if you grab this pawn with check
King up attacking your rook and you
can't come back with check because guess
what BAM that's why the rooks there and
suddenly the rooks gone and that's it
lights out push does nothing at all
because of the move Knight to e6 this
pawn is controlled this pawn is passed
and whites in deep trouble wife's dead
here so it looks as though Robson is
going to go down in
claims in this endgame he has real
trouble after this move if Nara disky
finds it the move rook to c1 defending
this pawn at a distance so the youngster
that is narrowed iski the youngest
player in the competition looks like
he's about to beat his elder by a little
ways and he has in fact played the move
and it looks like we're in the line and
it's just temporary after Knight takes d
6 if I may show the moves Knight takes d
6 king b 6 it looks like he's played
knight to be 7 in order to temporarily
save the rook that doesn't look like
he's gonna help at all that looks like
buss City so Robson about to lose yet
another game here in the championships
back to you guys
Wow big big turnaround because Rey was
chasing the phantom of an advantage he
got his rook deep into the opponent's
territory but unfortunately it looks
like he's lost his he's going to lose it
I think he's going to lose a rook after
Knight b7 King takes b7 d6 right if I
got this situation right oh I'm sorry
I'm not able to there's a rook beef I
thought he was going to lose the road
yeah well actually the 796 and I still
got this rook check on d5 so Knight b7
was the best resource in the position
but it's really hard for me to believe
that with the extra piece Danya
shouldn't just rope it in the point so
let's say after d6 we gotta have to move
our knight yeah and at some point we're
gonna get some position that looks a
little bit like this but that's an extra
piece and that's all she wrote so Nora
disky looking really good to win his
first game of the US Championships and
we have will get that checkmating
discussion
judge when we check my offer that's our
theory or just a brain thing brain spasm
brain spasm of course he was lost what
are you gonna do what are you gonna sew
Grand Master Alejandro Ramirez with
Maurice Ashley indeed with last year's
runner-up Grandmaster Ramirez welcome to
the show so tell us we need to know
Bishop g3 happens on the board a
grandmaster allows Knight g1 mate in one
was it because he's your friend he
wanted the audience to to get a pretty
picture what's the reasoning here well I
mean of course it's my friend but I
think sometimes when you are losing in a
position you try to hope for the best
and you forget some variations because
you're not double checking because okay
whatever happens happens you're already
lost and in this case I think okay
Bishop g3 is probably the only try that
doesn't lose instantly unless you forget
that 91 is checkmate so I guess he just
kind of forgot because I hovered over
the night and he resigned with a smile I
think he just kind of forgot that it was
checkmate I mean of course he's lost
anyways I guess that makes sense then
that he didn't do it in a gentleman's
fashion otherwise he would have actually
lets you play Knight g1 mate so right
probably I mean whatever I don't think
it's a big difference but yeah I think
he just forgot about the checkmate
indeed we had a smothered mane and
another board could have happened it's
rare that you get this one in actual
practice especially with a black King on
h3 that's a new one
you know it was it was actually quite
interesting because it seems like black
was creating a lot of counter play
bringing in the king and the Queen and
it seems like my king was a little weak
and the H pawn if it fell okay he got a
pass pawn but somehow or another he was
actually not threatening anything so I
could just advance my pawns and you know
he got try to create a lot of counter
play but the King just ended up being
Chuck made it I guess yeah indeed it's
funny because your pawns haven't gone
very far down the board
but just him trying to fight back
suddenly it's bait yeah kind of funny
that you think these pawns would at
least be more of a threat before all
that happened well they kind of art
because I mean they are i think one move
away from me being able to trade queens
and sacrifice my knight without needing
it for the advance
of the pawns they can they can just
overwhelm the bishop but so for that
reason he's in a little bit of a hurry
and on top of that he actually doesn't
have any constructive plan because
Bishop f4 was the only thing that looked
reasonable trying to attack tht to pawn
but that lost the Queen f2 and had he
done anything else it wouldn't have been
constructive to his position I can
suggested him as my pawn
indeed you sacrificed in exchange early
in this game if you don't mind just
showing that moment when when he played
Bishop h3 I move 11 ya just click on the
screen right there yeah you sacrifice in
exchange by taking on e5 did you feel
like this was gonna be super promising
for you I mean I thought at first that
he was doing something quite bad because
I thought okay Knight takes e5 Bishop
takes F 1 I take c6 he cannot take on
right we saw this line here actually he
could not actually take on f1 first
right because you just take the bishop
so I thought okay he's doing something
quite bad and then I realized okay he's
gonna play Bishop f6 first but the more
I looked at it I was like okay Knight
takes c6 Queen d7 it looks like the only
move for now of course not if I was the
only move and I thought in this position
if I somehow was able to consolidate I
would be strategically better because
okay his rooks are not particularly
powerful if the Knights can block it the
only issue was of course if I could get
my Knights back on back in time because
here I was up he was playing really
annoying moves like Bishop takes f1 of
course Queen takes f1 in he played Ruby
8 which is one of the many annoying
ideas he had and I wanted to just play
Knight c4 but I think the computer
agrees with me that it's not at such a
great move 94 Bishop takes c3 pawn takes
c3 and then after 95 he wants to quickly
exchange the night I know that yeah for
the fans let me just get rid of this and
if you don't mind just pressing a
variation so he'd take on c3
take on c3 Knight d5 and now his idea is
that if I defend the pawn he can very
quickly go Knight b6 + c4 it doesn't
matter how I defend the pawn on c3 and
then I be 64 and then this at least
would equalize because suddenly I don't
have a strong night and then what might
come my compensation for the rook okay
so have two pawns but
you know suddenly his activity might
overwhelmed me and I played something
which I'm sure that computer doesn't
like but the computers are quite bad in
this type of positions where it seems
like one side has a lot of initiative
but it's not so clear how to make
progress
I actually think 91 was the best winning
try because at this point if I'm able to
actually consolidate my position I'll be
in a very good situation and it's not so
clear how he's going to disrupt me from
doing it because it's very clear what I
want to do I want to play Knight c4
bishop somewhere you three or a four
rook C 1 B 3 Luke C 2 and once I get all
this he's strategically lost now of
course the computer says some random
stuff but unless it can show
convincingly that he can prevent me from
developing I think we're just a little
bit better you seem like you had a real
sense of what to do in this position
feeling good no doubt you're back on 50%
is it back on even yeah I'm back on even
which is good I mean I played quite
badly against Slenderman and I feel like
ok 50% is acceptable I've had one more
white than black so it's not ideal but
ok at least I'm not doing badly in the
tournament indeed so who do you play
tomorrow and what do you think about
your chances there sure I think I'm
playing a Cobian because I'm following
her i F normally but I'm not entirely
positive from that if it's a Cobian okay
he's always annoying to play against
because it's practiced quite good and
always very solid and he had just beat
Goliath so he'll be I mean I think he's
gonna beat Goliath in that same game
yeah I think so
I thought you graph was completely lost
yeah when did this happen
guys we missed this development yeah Wow
big development in the championship that
gives a Lenderman a sweet situation to
be in
what is he one full point ahead yes yeah
yeah of course grey made some strange
decisions in this game
he actually had a nice advantage from
the opening when he played I think in
this position night f3 was quite nice
because you cannot take on g2 this was a
ridiculous move it turns out because he
actually played Queen g5 on purpose yeah
he completely forgot that Queen G so you
can play King into it that's incredible
that he played this move and now I end
up winning the
shows that one bad move does the game
make yeah that chess is funny like that
and then at some point garea
allowed this HOF awful rock n game which
should still be may be drawn with
precise play but somehow he lost it very
quickly
yeah will ya take us through those
niceties but thanks so much for joining
us and good luck in the restaurant Thank
You Grandmaster Alejandra Ramirez
winning a fine game and looking to start
winning some more games here in these
championships back to you guys nice game
and good understanding by Alejandro I
really like the way he described what he
was trying to do keep as many pieces on
the peak on the board as possible after
he had delivered his sacrifice exchange
for two pawns grave has lost a version
of Kobe and so when you're writing off a
Kobe and as having an all draw
tournament and he has proven I was wrong
and I believe you knock 11 draws he's
won the game that we thought we had
already been off for him well he was
definitely worse out of the opening but
he did fight back and something went
enormous ly wrong she got a yab I guess
the position was here when things really
started getting confusing why would you
take with the rook I'm not the pond a4
and now g3 that sure looks like a waste
of time to me what I would try to do if
I were white is to trade this pawn I
would probably play something maybe it's
too slow I'm not sure something of this
nature trying to get this how am I gonna
how am I going to trade yeah right and
that just seems like maybe it's just
simply too slow I'm not sure but at
least if I could okay
I can maybe force this but what I'm
saying is I was trying okay obviously in
a
this almost reminds me of a soir ins
game that as soon as white could take
this pawn then he should make a draw
with a g4 pot so I mean if I was in
white shoes I would be trying to trade
off the a5 pawn for the b7 pawn right
let's compare that to the game because
the game was kind of similar to that
well he said what happened in the game
however was that white really did
nothing g3 and simply allowed black to
keep pushing his pawn down the board and
with both partly not both but but
allowing black to keep a pawn of his own
meant that well I think that this was
the resign that the move that carrieth
probably resigned from something I can't
see three g5 and the whole point here is
that as we get to some situation like
this sure that's why you want to show
those pawns because we're envisioning
the scenario where it would be a draw
exactly because he in the apron off and
version of call he is smiling difference
between a draw a smile or just a regular
smile and a smile after you win a game
we're about to find out
trust me Janet it probably has to do
with depth and size you know they're
really big studies but var will be very
proud of his move Queen g5 I'm sure
anything like to explain his deep deep
insight for people at home because he
made a mistake which of his level is
kind of similar to what a lot of
everybody you play you play chess you're
gonna make a mistake that's full stop
just deal with it
is that what he did even that's what
he's very impressive in Parisian also a
fan of many people here in st. Louis is
he is the cast he's one of the major
cast members of the rotating crew of
grandmasters that comes in to give
lessons and luck
and you can follow a lot of those on
YouTube and with no further ado here he
is with Maurice Ashley about his first
win here at the u.s. championship
Indy thanks Jen were with our Grand
Master version of Kobe and welcome to
the show so we had a funny moment in the
beginning we saw this move Queen to g5
attacking the pawn and we all wondered
what you're gonna do after Knight f3
since you were losing a queen Oh what
did it feel like when you realize oops I
can't take that pawn yeah I just I was
expecting him to play Knight f3 first
instant of Bishop d3 to prevent Queen g5
but when he played Bishop d3 I played
kind of quickly and I missed that when
he plays Knight f3 Queen g2 I wish to
move King g2 and then suddenly the Queen
is trapped so I had to go back to f6 I
basically lost the tempo and what would
you think you said were you kicking
yourself like what the heck that I just
do yeah I mean to be honest if I don't
play Queen g5 I've already equalized the
game I should just play Queen f6 and
then 96 and Bishop f5 as soon as I can
exchange the light square bishop should
be equal so I thought you okay you know
I'm slightly worse now but I still have
to fight so it wasn't that bad now the
game did proceed in a way where he
looked like he was hunting you down like
Knight b6 e 4 and then he caught your
king in the middle of the board how did
you feel when this movie very strong I
thought you know because in fact the
move g6 I'm not sure if that's the best
move because I had two options there I
could play Bishop e6 or even h6 but g6 I
felt like kind of safe I mean clearly
he's better here but I didn't see any
concrete ways for him to break through I
think he's you know slightly better
maybe a little bit more but I'm still
solid now what you got the time control
it looked like you were worse you were
down upon for a hot minute and then you
got a chance to clean up the Queen side
pawns if you don't mind showing move
around move 40 there I think the turning
point here is actually here where he
played the move king h2 because I think
King h2 is in accuracy because it leaves
the f2 pawn hanging because my night is
coming Conde 3 here I'm down upon but I
actually have some contra play here
because my knight is very active ninety
five ninety three so I'm slightly worse
here
but here we were both kind of longtime
my surprise yeah you took I think it was
just a bad move because you know he is
up two pounds but I will just win one of
these pants and I did I will just have a
lot of contra play I think I might being
in accuracy and here yeah I took the
pawn on f2 because it's important to
take the healthy palm and then try to
win the weak one yes so I took I think
here I'm already absolutely fine I
thought I was slightly better here
actually were you thinking win now or we
think and just just get that I'm trying
to make the time control have that much
time so we play a few more moves here
now you jumped really quickly after
several moves bringing your rook up
taking the pawn defending and I think
right around here if you go back a
second I thought King g5 was very
interesting here for him this move King
g5 I was a bit worried about it because
you know King is active and then he
plays Knight to f4 so I I think I'm safe
after 94 but I thought this was a better
alternative now we didn't see the end of
the game so please take us through this
ending because it looked like - all
rights he should be drawing here you
trade it off pieces and and got to this
rook ending well you look like you're
slightly better you played this
interesting move rook 287 yeah because I
was thinking about rookie 5 but then it
should be a draw because he wins the
pawn on b7 so I want to put the rook on
h7 protect my h5 point which is very
important and then try to push the sea
pound very quickly I think this is still
a draw but he needs to play precisely
and he just made I think she mistakes
his mistakes where he played he started
with a for this King if I move is a very
strong move because I was expecting to
play you know c5 first but if I play c5
he has a 6 and then if I capture he has
rook f6 check so that's why King g5 is
very important to prevent that because I
need to keep the b7 pawn here right
without a b7 pawn it's a draw so that's
why I need to keep the pawn and I think
here I think the final mistake was I
think here it's just as soon as I put a
rock on see maybe he miss Rooke c7 maybe
that'll score okay J but Roxy 7 is just
lost because C pawn is very quick even
though he wins the pawn I just push and
you always
once we have the look behind the
passport so here's just lost because I
will win it's rook and then collect the
pawns and an amazing turn of events
great defense on your part after a
mistake you know there was a joke that
maybe you're trying to draw your way to
that half Fisher prize but it looks like
you didn't have that on your mind so you
you finally got a win
good good score to be sure at +1 in the
championships and you you kind of turned
his tide back a little bit you're the
number four play in the tournament what
are you thinking about moving from this
position I'm just you know I'm glad to
win a game because you know to be honest
the first few rounds was frustrating and
you know I wasn't getting anything with
white and I'm really happy to win again
with black and you know I'm looking
forward for the rest of the tournament
so I just need to continue fight the way
I played today even though I made a
mistake in opening but I think the rest
of the game I kind of played well and
fought back my real fighter today
congratulations and we wish you the best
in the rest of this ornament thank you
rap master version of Cobian after a
fighting win number four point in the
tournament no one should ignore his
possibility of maybe winning the
championship back to you kidding yes
very exciting turn around and do up all
of our results in oh okay in the Women's
Championship is the task II was able to
hold that fortress against me as you
pointed out some mistakes there and both
sides under the pressure but a really
instructive endgame definitely so if you
weren't there to hear about all of Yasir
thoughts and that I encourage you rewind
the tape or they are wonderful or Tonya
as you call him yes have fought his
first game of the event yeah sorry sorry
DeRay but Bravo Dania that was also
another turnaround big result though
that win by a KO bein heavyweight
matchup we saw it already
gari of camps ki and that was such a
short draw that it really left a sour
taste in our mouths that this game today
was a great fight and winning with black
is a super bonus
now blend arrangement you set up for you
before we close today but as you were
saying yeah Lindemann a clear point
point clear of the field being chased by
a lot of very strong players the US
Championship and we talked about a
player who looked like they were worse
and then ended up actually winning the
game we also have a player who in the
Women's Championship look like she was
going down and she saved the draw so
today is all about saving yourself from
worse positions if the top players in
the country can do it then you guys at
home to never give up we have a list of
elaqid out with Maurice Ashley indeed FM
Alyssa Miller Tina Alyssa you look gone
you look dead how do you how did you
feel in this position right here and how
did you come back to be able to draw
this game yeah I felt like my only
chance was if she simplified early into
an end game and I could somehow win back
the d3 pawn and that's essentially what
ended up happening I thought that after
all the captures on d3 she should have
just kept the tension when somewhere
like rook c8 because it's so difficult
for me to maneuver but she probably
thought that an end game would be a
simpler win but as we know what with
rook endings drawers are always in the
air indeed we had a conversation I
believe it was yesterday where you said
it seems like for you the difficulty is
converting good positions is your
technique what do you think is did she
fall into the kind of trap that you fall
into in the past yeah absolutely yeah it
looks like she just made you know second
best moves and eventually the advantage
fizzled out now how are you feeling
though at this moment well I mean this
has to be just you I mean she's all over
you in this position did you did you
think that you did have a chance or were
you just just making moves just because
it was important for me in this position
to realign my thinking because I started
out white grand-prix attack first time
I'm playing that opening you know very
aggressive and here I have to realize
that okay now I'm fighting for a draw so
I think it's important to change your
mindset here and and start thinking
about how do I make it difficult for her
to convert the advantage that's kind of
hard to do though right when
when you're first thinking attack win
and now it's completely different it's
save the draw yeah I mean it it's not
simple but it had to be done here and
you know thankfully and in the end game
I managed to pull off a draw with the
mismatch so how are you feeling going
into the next game um you know I'm
definitely not that proud of this game
but I was able to fight on and that's
important for me and I will bring
fighting trusts tomorrow
great well good save and we wish you the
best in the rest of your games Thanks
FM Alyssa mellow Heena survival you got
to survive Gloria Gaynor I will survive
right that's the theme here at the
championships back to you guys an old
expression of Grand Master Larry Evans
where there's life there's hope and that
was a hopeful save by ELISA today but
you had a plan for saving she was she
she really have like this is my plan
this is my one whole new trick I try to
take her indirect ending where maybe she
has more experience than our opponent
yeah don't give up even you know it's
funny how the top players are just so
confident because we thought this
position was really bad like have lures
yeah I think objectively the truth or
somewhere in between
but right I think that feeling that
you're only a little worse keep some
super attentive and not too hard on
himself yeah he I believe he
overestimated his position I thought he
was a lot worse I mean I was really
surprised that he kind of came in and
said you know like I defended a
defendant and now it's my turn to win
you know I but in any case very
impressive you don't beat team or Gary
of very easily and to beat him from a
worse position well that's a real
success another big winner today who we
thought was in trouble at some point
Daniel narrowed its gear with his first
victory of this event
he's worried Ashley yes I'm with the
youngest competitor on the male side in
the competition Grandmaster Daniel
Nordisk II congratulations on your win
first tell us about this finish clearly
you're completely winning and your
opponent in this position played rook to
e5
check yeah I mean the thing is after f65
it's close to sale made but of course
yeah King 65 it was even he can take
your pawn unfortunately for him then we
could just change the rules around a
little bit guys uh-huh he could have had
a beautiful stalemate yeah unfortunately
no you were in trouble it looked like in
the beginning or lazy played this very
interesting novelty never seen the
answer Berlin I mean that what did you
think when you saw them well of course I
don't usually play the Berlin I I just
my goal is to get Rey and some more of a
sort of positional quiet ending of
course he's known for his very dangerous
opening preparation and you know I know
Bishop g5 and Bishop takes c6 is the
main move D takes e5 but I've never seen
Bishop a4 it was an unbelievable idea
and it's you know technically I guess
it's pretty logical because my knight on
d6 blocks the center shows opposition if
you don't mind just this press right at
the moment there so 96 and he played
Bishop a4 and I don't know if it was
ever played yeah we didn't we didn't
know find this move I'm gonna have to do
our research but this line led to a
straight loss of a pawn and he still
looked like he had very good company
yeah the 96 was sort of the bane of my
existence and I calculated a lot of
lines and I figured I had settled for a
slightly worse but extremely solid
position after Bishop g5 so when the
position started turning a little bit
when did you start thinking I can with
this game ah that's a good question I
think I think it was the ending because
well I thought the ending was just about
even maybe he had a very slight Pole but
when he played I think rook a7 was it it
was somewhere here might be three no
this was it was earlier
yeah real case here when he played 37
work a6 perhaps it is objectively the
best move but he was a very cute time
trouble and obviously the rook is very
close to being trapped so I figured that
even though he's he's an amazing
tactician and a great calculator it
would still be difficult to to save the
rook I mean it's easy to air in this
position yeah rook trapped rookies a
trap yeah and my play is significantly
more straightforward
I really have that many choices indeed a
fine win in the end trapping that rook
this is your first win in the
championship
first win has got to feel pretty good
what are you thinking going forward yeah
I mean it feels great it's good to sort
of I don't know break the ice somehow of
course there was some degree of lock
involved but I thought you know I played
well throughout sort of didn't really
make any mistakes just kept solid and I
was rewarded for it so yeah I'm really
happy and hopefully I can continue the
trend we hope so - so good luck in the
rest of the channel very much
Grandmaster Daniel now Radetzky I love
when these fighters talk about luck like
they don't make good moves back to you
Jenny yes that's all for today we've got
all of our results in let me go over
quickly through the stand it's good
right now there are a lot of players
chasing renderman as you pointed out
some pretty strong players four points
ahead of the field but look who's behind
him grave even though he lost the game
Kamsky own Ashok Anna Cobian might a
wolf pack right right I was gonna say
the wolf pack yeah that's well with
those layers at the Olympiad so good
point by the way the winner it does in
fact qualify for the US team and in the
ladies and in the ladies we have Irena
crashing she's only ahead by half a
point because the tan ski did save Wow
so that's still sitting out there behind
so that still sets up for a
winner-take-all kind of match in the
penultimate right round eight ladies
that's right and we have some final
words for Maurice indeed we have five
rounds under our belts on the men's side
and four on the women's side tomorrow
the women go to play their midpoint game
right the fifth game of the championship
so sitting pretty certainly has got to
be arena crushed she is just playing
some wonderful chess today was one that
she will put in her best games book far
off into the future I'm sure but she'll
remember this one for quite some time on
as a ton ski though remember that first
round game she had against arena Zegna
where she had to fight to survive
that's what her theme is she puts up
such resistance she knows she needs to
say well within reach of her main rival
we also have to say the 13 heroes got to
feel a little bit disappointed ashrita
Iran not winning a dominant position but
hopefully she can clear her head and
keep playing moving forward on the men's
side Lenderman
I'm just totally impressed but yeah as
you called it the Wolf Pack the Olympic
team a bunch of gangsters are chasing
him right now he has to really keep his
preparation together and tight and see
whether or not he can keep this lead
going into the future round so it's a
really exciting part of the
championships well we hope that you will
stay tuned for every minute huh we will
be back tomorrow at the usual time so
whether you're here in st. Louis or
you're watching from home join us
tomorrow at 1:00 central to Eastern for
round six of the US Championship and run
five of the us salute championship
this is Jennifer jihadi and I'm signing
off for Grand Master's yeah sir Selwyn
and where exactly